and finally new rule Batman and Superman
have to explain something to me why are
you two fighting you're supposed to work
together I saw it on my footie pajamas
it's unsettling to see two beloved
mythical figures go at it it's like
watching Jesus beat up a unicorn and I
think the same thing when I see
Democrats these days you two also need
to work together so you can stop the
greatest super villain of all time
Orange Crush
now it was an exciting week for us left
leaners because with the win in Michigan
the Sanders campaign which I have been
saying is offering America a new kind of
deal has shown that Americans are still
considering that deal but I feel I
should say something about a growing
movement called Bernie or bust where
Bernie supporters pledged that if it
celery
they'll stay home or vote for the Green
Party on their website they say they're
revolting against the plutocracy no
actually you'll be helping elect a
plutocrat who's revolting Elizabeth
Warren recently disappointed Bernie
supporters by staying neutral
in the primary fight no endorsement for
either one so thousands of Sanders fans
hijacked her Facebook page and said
things like I'm disgusted by you why not
just throw the whole country under the
bus it must be Karl Rove's money and
those were the early comments before the
red bull kicked it really Elizabeth
Warren is the enemy now she's helped
more Millennials than at a roll
and the Hillary camp does it too in a
race where no Republican candidate
supports a woman's right to choose and
one of them calls women pimp bimbos and
pigs you know the real sexist is Bernie
Bill Clinton accused his supporters of
online sexism which is pretty rich
coming from a guy who's been known to
grab your tits in person so while Bernie
fans attack Hillary for not being
liberal enough and Hillary fans attack
Bernie for not being feminist enough
black lives matter is attacking them
both for not being black enough even
though they both have a 100 percent
voter rating from the n-double-a-cp
as opposed to trump who gets five stars
from the KKK
there are real enemies out there have
you seen a Republican debate the zombies
are in the mall
I'm telling you this is going to be the
death of liberals this nitpicky
intramural attacking of friends for
insufficient purity compulsively
cleaning up a little corner of the room
and it's already quite clean well there
are giant piles of [ __ ] everywhere else
last year social justice warriors
swarmed on Matt Damon for saying gay
actors should not be defined by their
sexuality which was interpreted as him
saying gay actors should stay in the
closet
the daily beast screamed shut up Matt
Damon Washington Post
he's got Damon splainin to do
and Vox said Matt Damon isn't a terrible
person he's just ignorant right the real
obstacle to gays achieving equality is
Matt Damon in fact he's such a homophobe
II [ __ ] Liberace
last year Dolce and Gabanna got their
gates it caught in the liberal ringer
when when they expressed one
conservative view on artificial
insemination and this week oh they
[ __ ] up again but luckily the brave
virtual vigilantes of the internet were
there to condemn these two evil old
Queens before get this crime selling a
shoe that they're calling a slave sandal
but look at it it's a happy slave sandal
now clearly they should update the name
and call it an intern sandal
but in this month when we found out that
20% of Trump voters believed that the
end of slavery itself was a bad idea
this is what motivates you to write a
scathing blog post a thoughtlessly named
shoe we'll hold on to your hats guys
because right now I'm wearing black
loafers